Bei jedem endoskopischen Eingriff wird auch ein Endoskop natürlich verwendet.
Diese Instrumente unterscheiden sich geringfügig, aber die Erklärung oder Aufklärung hierfür ist im Wesentlichen eigentlich immer ähnlich oder gleich.
Sie sagen zum Beispiel, wir verwenden bei diesem Eingriff ein spezielles Instrument.
Das ist ein langer, dünner Schlauch. Entweder sagen Sie dann etwa so dick wie ein kleiner Finger mit einer Lichtquelle und Kamera am Ende.
Oder im Falle zum Beispiel das Herzkatheter, sagen Sie, etwa 3 mm dick.
Die Gastroskopie oder ÖGD.
Wir möchten bei Ihnen eine sogenannte Magenspiegelung, auch Gastroskopie genannt, durchführen.
Bei diesem Eingriff können wir das Innere der Speiseröhre des Magens und des 12-Fingerdahms mit einer Kamera ansehen.
Dabei verwenden wir ein langes, dünnes Instrument, etwa so dick wie ein kleiner Finger.
Sie können sich das wie ein Schlauch vorstellen, der eine Lichtquelle und Kamera am Ende hat.
Wir führen diesen Schlauch über den Mund und die Speiseröhre bis in den Magen und den 12-Fingerdahm ein.
Der Eingriff wird normalerweise ohne Narkose durchgeführt, sie können aber ein Beruhigungsmittel bekommen und erhalten auch eine örtliche Betäubung des Rachens.
Sollten wir eine Blutung sehen, dann können wir die Blutung in vielen Fällen direkt während des Eingriffs stillen.
Entweder nähen wir das blutende Gefäß oder wir spritzen ein Medikament in die Schleimhaut, um die Blutung zu stellen.
Das ist aber optional, wenn es nötig ist, dann natürlich auch der Teil der Biopsy zu erklären, aufzuklären.
Und bei Risik und Komplikation sagt man, dies ist ein risikoarme Routine-Eingriff, dennoch können in seltenen Fällen Komplikationen auftreten
und dann erfolgt die entsprechende Aufklärung der relevanten Komplikation.